hello everyone welcome to another
Science and Technology q a for kids and
others and I see we have a bunch of
saved up questions here and one that
just caught my eye is are there nuclear
reactions going on inside our bodies
well so
the answer is probably a very few but
not many but let's explain so
when we have an atom there's
a nucleus in the middle which has
protons and neutrons all bound together
very tightly and then there are
electrons far away from the nucleus and
the nucleus is a certain size and the
kind of distance the the uh the
electrons are maybe a hundred thousand
times further away than the edge of the
nucleus so to speak so it's it's a
pretty the an atom has a lot of empty
space in it
and most of what happens in biology in
our bodies has to do with chemical
reactions and chemical reactions have to
do with the electrons in different atoms
interacting with each other so for
example what can happen is there can be
an electron that gets pulled from one
atom to another atom when an electron is
pulled out that means that the the
charge of the nucleus the electric
charge of the nucleus is no longer
completely canceled by the other
electrons in in just if you just have a
an atom sitting by itself there'll be a
certain number of protons in the nucleus
as well as neutrons and a certain number
of electrons in the atom and if there
are let's say I don't know
um
I count up my elements if there are
um six protons
in the nucleus that means it has an
electric charge of plus six and then if
there's kind of just a separated atom
there'll be six electrons also in that
atom which contribute a minus six charge
so the whole atom is electrically
neutral but if you pull one of those
electrons away then there'll be a piece
of electric charge that's uncansled from
the nucleus and that will lead for
example two atoms to perhaps attract
each other or repel each other
electrically so but most of what happens
in US biologically is the electrons of
atoms interacting with each other the
nuclei of atoms never really get near
each other and they have a hard time
getting near each other because they
have an electric charge and the rule for
electric charges is if you have charges
of the same sign they repel each other
so two positive charges will try and
push each other apart if you have a
positive charge and a negative charge
then they'll attract each other so
nuclei all have positive charges and so
they're they're kind of shielded by this
by these electrons but the nuclei
themselves uh even though most of the
atom is empty space so most of the time
when atoms are bumping up against each
other and interacting and their
electrons interacting the nuclei are
just uh you know these tiny bits in the
middle and if they were to get close
they would tend to push each other away
electrically
that's what happens most of the time now
there is
a tiny probability that these two nuclei
first there's a small probability the
nuclei will kind of be lined up so
they'll be near each other and the
second thing is there's a tiny
probability that even though you might
think these nuclei would repel each
other then in fact they will be able to
interact and essentially get get very
close to each other and that happens
because of uh well it's it's because of
a quantum mechanics phenomenon called
tunneling
um it's the main main effect there uh
and um
I think let me think about this for a
second what um okay so so what's the
point of if the two nuclei in a nucleus
there are lots of protons they all have
positive charge how come the nucleus
doesn't fly apart well the answer is
there's this thing called the strong
nuclear force which keeps the nucleus
held together but the strong nuclear
force while it can while it attracts
protons to protons protons to neutrons
and so on doesn't have any effect on
electrons but the strong nuclear force
is very short range so its range is
about a thousand trillionth of a meter
um so if you take these protons and you
make them more than a thousand trillion
per meter apart then they'll just be
electrically repelling each other and
they'll be pushed apart but if you can
get them really close into that
thousandth trillionth of a meter then
they'll attract each other through the
strong nuclear force and they'll get
stuck together and one of the things
that happens is if you take two nuclei
and you can get them close enough that
the strong nuclear force takes over uh
those two nuclei will be just pulled
together and you'll release a bunch of
energy associated with the fact that the
the nuclei when they're pulled together
the the sort of there's binding energy
that gets released when the things get
pulled together and can be in single
unit and that's the effect of nuclear
fusion and so on
um to uh
in um uh and and that's what powers for
example the Sun and so on but so the
question is does that ever happen in our
bodies and the answer is there is a tiny
rate of uh of effusion reactions that
happen when even when you think that you
know in the Sun the temperature is you
know 10 million degrees and all these
all these uh atoms are traveling at very
high speeds because that's what happens
at you know the speed of the atoms is
proportional to their temperature
actually the the
the the square of the speed is
proportional to their temperature
um and uh the um uh but the the hotter
the gases the faster things will be
going and when they're going fast enough
just their pure momentum will sort of
overcome the barrier associated with
um uh electric repulsion and the things
we'll be able to to fuse
um that doesn't happen that way for um
uh uh ordinary uh when when in in our
bodies you know our temperature is
whatever it is you know 98.6 degrees
Fahrenheit 90 37 degrees Centigrade
whatever
um at that temperature these
um
um atoms are traveling at at speeds very
low compared to the speeds they're
traveling at in the Sun that would cause
them to to be able to overcome the
electric propulsion and fuse
so
uh how do they how do any of them ever
manage to do that well the answer is
that in quantum mechanics
the main sort of feature of quantum
mechanics is that many different things
happen it isn't the case that when
you're you know aiming these two atoms
at each other that there's just one path
that the two atoms follow instead there
are many different paths they follow and
those many different paths there's sort
of a whole range of different parts they
all have a certain chance of happening
and quantum mechanics is kind of the
story of all those different possible
paths well there are some paths that
will cause these atoms to for example
end up with nuclei that fuse or whatever
else those piles are just very rare
those paths are exponentially rare that
the the chance of getting one of those
paths it depends on on sort of how much
energy you have to overcome and things
like this
um but it's sort of an exponentially
small probability one can probably work
out what it is if I think about it a bit
um I think that's the main effect that
will cause a tiny number of fusion
events to happen I don't know how often
they would happen it'll be rare that's
that's one sort of type of nuclear
reaction thing
um it's by the way uh you know when
people talk about making Fusion
reactions and so on and people say well
I made this sort of home uh home kit
that's made by the sort of Home
accelerator of um uh where I just um I'm
making protons go at high speed or
something by just having an electrical
something like an old cathode ray tube
um uh with with Electrical uh Electric
fields in it and so on and they say I've
made some fusion yes they make a tiny
bit of fusion but not just not very much
just not enough to be interesting in
terms of releasing the energy you need
to make actual power from Fusion there's
one more effect I might mention about
radioactivity and what about um uh
nuclear reactions in in our bodies which
is nuclear decay
so
most of the time when you have a nucleus
of an atom it'll just sit there happily
for forever but some nuclei are unstable
they undergo radioactive decay there are
different types of radioactive decay
um but there is there are some
substances that
um so so if something decays very
quickly then then it will all have
decayed in a second or something like
this
um so there won't be any of it around
but there are a few uh types of nuclei
that last a really long time like
billions of years so those nuclei if
they were created
um at the when the Earth was created
there's still some of them around so
that's the case with uranium-235 for
example it's the case with a few other
um radioactive isotopes those types of
materials don't typically get in our
bodies those heavy metals the the um the
things on the end of the periodic table
um we don't use those biologically and
those things are just a nuisance
biologically and they they poison us if
if we get lots of them them in us so
most of those things don't show up as um
uh as as sort of examples of nuclei that
are self-destructing in our bodies there
are some others that do radon as an
example of one that does sometimes
um it's something where there are uh
there's a okay there's actually another
effect I could mention which is cosmic
rays
um boy I always think these questions
that seem like they're easy will turn
out to be easy there there's always the
ones that have all these stings in their
tail okay this question is more
complicated than I thought
um so another another case is
radioactive decay of which
um uh radon is the I I would suspect is
the primary example of something which
can get in one's body and then undergo
radioactive decay which means it's
nucleus to self-destructing which is
kind of a nuclear process so to speak
the other thing that could happen is
cosmic rays
so the Earth is constantly bombarded by
particles that are coming particularly
from the Sun but also from actually all
over the universe they're mostly protons
they're mostly
um have uh an energy the the um uh let's
see how to explain the energy the energy
um
well it's about equal to the rest mass
of the proton it's about
um which means that they're going at a
significant fraction of the speed of
light
um these protons hit the upper
atmosphere they typically will produce a
a shower of other particles at sea level
it's particularly muons are particles
that get produced if you go up to a
higher altitude or you're on a plane or
something like that
um you'll you'll see more of the kind of
um
primary
um cosmic ray protons
um and uh
um that um
uh that that's the so so anyway these
these cosmic rays
um are coming at a rate so if you have a
little going through uh something the
size of us at sea level you'll have a
cosmic ray going through you a few times
a minute
if you go on a plane you'll have cosmic
rays going through you uh uh every few
seconds
um and those cosmic rays have particles
in them which are energetic enough that
if they hit a nucleus they will cause a
nuclear reaction a nuclear they'll cause
something to happen to that nucleus
they'll make the nucleus self-destruct
they'll they'll have other uh reactions
in that nucleus so that's another source
of uh kind of nuclear processes
um in us and as I say I suspect that
um well it's a little different because
a proton hitting us is very likely to
have a nuclear reaction
um the by the time you get to sea level
most of the protons that arrived in the
primary primary Cosmic radiation
um have already interacted at least once
and one when the protons interact they
hit protons they hit nuclei in in the
air in the oxygen and nitrogen in the
air and they'll produce a shower of
other particles maybe 50 other particles
100 other particles sometimes
um actually the the ones at the peak of
the energy Spectrum will probably only
produce a couple of other particles it's
the the higher energy ones will produce
many more particles but the and so
they'll produce these particles and when
when you hit a nucleus like that one of
the things that comes out are things
called pions pions are the particles
that are being exchanged between protons
and neutrons and protons and protons and
so on they're the the primary carriers
of the strong nuclear force and they're
particles that have a mass of about a
tenth the mass of the proton
um and they have a kind of a uh that
they're constantly being exchanged
inside the nucleus if you kind of bash a
nucleus with another proton you'll
typically sort of knock some ions out of
the nucleus and pions are unstable they
Decay
um the uh the the most kind of well the
the three different kinds positive
charge negative charge a neutral zero
charge ions and the uh the positive and
negative charge pions decay in 100
millionth of a second and the um uh
um
and the the neutral one decays in a 10
billionth of a second
um so they Decay very quickly
um and they Decay into these particles
called muons which are kind of like
heavy versions of electrons electron
muons are also unstable they decay in
about two microseconds two millionths of
a second
um and uh uh but those muons
they typically reach the Earth's surface
um as the prime as the main cosmic rays
that that hit the surface
they are as I say like heavy electrons
they have an electric charge they don't
participate in the strong nuclear force
and so when they hit things they can
have sort of an electrical effect on
those things but not directly a nuclear
effect on those things they can disrupt
a nucleus but they can't do so by by
using the strong nuclear force so to
speak they're just doing it by using
electromagnetic uh electrical forces and
and as I say muons decaying about two
microseconds
um just to make things even more
complicated because the new ones are
traveling at high speed as a result of
having been produced by a particle that
hit the atmosphere at high speed the
muons are typically going at a
significant fraction of the speed of
light and there's this phenomenon of
time dilation which causes things that
are going faster to uh kind of think
that less time has passed for them and
so the two microseconds lifetime of muon
is actually extended for a muon that's
traveling last of the muam was traveling
right at the speed of light its lifetime
will be infinitely extended but it would
also be infinitely hard to get the muon
to travel that fast but in practice the
lifetimes the muons and cosmic rays are
significantly more than two microseconds
which is why they survive getting down
to the surface and make that kind of
cosmic ray uh the the flux of cosmic
rays at the surface but anyway that will
be another effect that causes some kind
of nuclear reactions to happen inside
inside our bodies
let's see
all right
there's a lot of questions yeah sorry I
thought that one was going to be easy
gosh
um
Tad asks here do you think it will ever
be possible to replace damaged brain
Parts with computational parts as
another form of prosthesis
well
the answer is surely yes
uh
our brains are essentially electrical
devices we have about 80 billion neurons
in our brains 90 billion neurons in our
brains each neuron is connected to maybe
100 or a thousand other neurons by
little tiny fibers and what's happening
is each neuron maybe a thousand times a
second a neuron will produce an
electrical pulse and it'll send that
electrical pulse to other neurons and
that whole electrical collection of
electrical processors is what eventually
builds up to make our thoughts and those
electrical signals are eventually
Amplified effectively to make our
muscles move and things like this
so
the the brain is really an electrical
device
we don't uh one of the things we don't
know is going from that low level
individual components individual neurons
the the 90 billion of them or whatever
two sort of things that aggregate up to
complete thoughts and saying the next
word I'm going to say and things like
this we don't really understand that
stack of how that works and so we don't
really understand exactly what's
important about that collection
electrical activity for example we know
that a single neuron if you make the
neuron if you kind of get it really
excited you might think oh it'll produce
more Electrical uh it'll have a sort of
a a bigger electrical voltage or current
or something like that that's not how it
works instead the neuron produces a
series of spikes it'll have it'll kind
of produce an electrical parts another
electrical pulse another electrical
pulse when a neuron gets really excited
it it has a spike train that has this
whole series of spikes so instead of a
neuron sort of increasing its its
voltage or something like that then
instead just fires more often and for
example when you look at those Spike
trains or you listen to those Spike
trains they'll have a lot of complicated
structure I mean we're going
and nobody really knows whether the
details of kind of the sequence of of
times when those spikes occur whether
that's important or not or whether all
that really matters is there's a spike
Trend going on from that neuron or there
isn't one or the neurons are sitting
there doing nothing so that's an example
of when you when you want to sort of
plug into the system you kind of need to
know what about the system is important
and what's not
but the the question of can we make
something which is kind of like a
pretend neuron that connects to a piece
of the brain that's something that we
can expect will will happen and I think
that uh there are there have been for a
long time kind of basic
um uh things like deep brain stimulation
devices that produce electrical signals
that affect neurons now now sometimes
they'll have very tiny wires that will
try and kind of get to the point where
they can poke at one neuron at a time so
to speak and that will be increasingly
possible people have built arrays that
are implantable arrays that go on like
the surface of the brain or can be
implanted inside the brain that have
kind of a raise of of places where
electrical activity can happen and where
they get small enough you can expect to
have each one of those touch a single
neuron now the problem is the inner
language of the brain we just don't know
what it is it's like uh we know
individual neurons oh that neuron is
firing and sometimes we know for some
neurons we know that neuron fires when
this particular thing happens so for
example there are neurons in our primary
visual cortex at the back of our heads
that are connected to uh particular
places on the retinas in our eyes and so
if you say if you have a spot of light
at that place on the retina that will
cause a particular neuron in your
primary visual cortex to start firing or
more complicatedly if you have a certain
pattern if you have something which has
you know black in the middle white on
the outside they're a particular centers
around cells in the primary visual
cortex which will say oh yeah I care
about that and we'll start firing
similarly the ones where if there's
Motion in particular directions they'll
start firing color at particular times
they'll start firing and so on and so
there's there's a certain amount where
we know what is the meaning of that
individual neuron but most of the time
in the neurons that deal with kind of
higher brain function we don't really
know there's just a complicated set of
neurons firing and the end result is
that we have a thought of some kind now
you know if we look at the same thing
for a computer we'd probably conclude
more or less the same kind of thing if
you look from the outside at all of
those different uh transistors and which
ones have a firing at each particular
time and so on it's a very complicated
pattern of stuff that's happening in the
case of a computer not a thousand times
a second but more like a billion times a
second that these transistors are active
although a computer typically
many things computers do a smaller
fraction of its transistors are active
than the fraction of our neurons that
are active in a typical moment in our
brains at least that's probably true and
and so
the um but you know if you tried to look
at the computer from sort of from the
outside and say what's this thing doing
it'd be really hard to tell we're in the
same situation with the brain we have
one big Advantage about the brain which
is that the brain learns and these
neurons the the typical way in which
they seem to learn is when they have
seen a firing pattern let's say they're
connected to a thousand other neurons
they see a certain pattern of firing of
those neurons they see which neurons
fire together with the other neurons
they kind of learn oh this firing this
is the way it usually works okay I will
enhance that way of making it work
that's a simple form of learning in
individual neurons and so these neurons
they kind of learn their activity based
on the things that they see happening
and so one can potentially make use of
that if you say I've just got this
electrical connection to these neurons I
don't know what it does well the neurons
the other neurons to which it's
connected Can potentially learn from the
things that are going on and so for
example one can expect that just as
people learn I mean you know we all we
all learn
um you know at um we you'll learn to
make use of our of our brains and our
nerves and so on
um and we have to kind of learn that
separately each person has to learn that
separately I mean you you learn kind of
how to see by the fact that you're the
the there are there are pieces of your
of your brain that are sort of wired up
to be connected to different parts of
the retina but when we're when we're in
the first I don't know a few months of
life we're noticing oh these pixels on
our retina tend to be lit up together
and so that causes our brain to kind of
start being able to recognize objects
and so on and start saying those pixels
are together they represent an object
and things like this and for example
people who for one reason or another
have uh the the they have Vision issues
in early life that that that part of
their brain won't be properly connected
so for example a common thing is this
condition called amblyopia where you
know one eye has some just as very
short-sighted or whatever else
um and um
nearsighted or whatever else and and so
sort of all of the all of the seeing is
going on in the other eye and and if you
know people typically don't notice that
until kids are a few years old and uh
then when what will happen is the eye
that was just not optically very good
won't you won't won't be being used all
the seeing Will Go On Through the eye
that is working well well then you know
the the the fixes you patch the eye
that's seeing well you fix the Optics of
the eye that wasn't seeing well and then
the kid and their brain learns to see
and it's it's and the fact that that's
possible to learn to see and one can
tell that's what's really going on once
learning to see by by recognizing these
sort of correlations between different
things in in the visual field and so on
and so that's the way that that that uh
you know you you've now got the the the
sensor data coming in correctly through
the eye when you fix the Optics of that
and now the brain has to kind of learn
to process that data and I strongly
suspect that when it comes to kind of
neural prosthesis but being putting in
um uh putting in sort of direct
connections electrical connections into
the brain that's the same type of thing
that you'll you'll get this thing that's
there and you'll gradually learn how to
make use of that thing now in the case
of a vision we know there are these sort
of correlations in the world there's a
you know blob of pixels here and there's
usually pixels nearby that are the same
color or whatever else because there are
objects extent of extended size and so
in a sense the responsibility of that
sort of uh thing that's connected
directly to the brain is is to provide
something about which to which the brain
which can make sense to the brain If you
say I'm going to feed into the brain the
stuff that the brain's never going to
understand it's not going to work but
the you know what what if if it's
something where the brain can learn that
stuff then you have a better chance to
be able to have something where you can
make that connection to to that um kind
of electronic device now what it's going
to feel like when one's able to do that
I don't really know I mean I kind of
feel like we have a certain sort of
symbiosis with our computers now we're
kind of uh you know there are lots of
things that I rely on my computer to do
including remember certain kinds of
things for me and so on but my formal
interaction is I'm typing things with my
fingers and I'm looking at things with
my eyes
um now if there was a direct connection
into some part of the brain uh you know
what would that feel like I think the
answer is uh one would learn to be able
to make use of that just like one can
learn to make use of you know if one is
driving a car or something like that you
learn to take this thing that is not
part of your body but yet control it in
a way that kind of feels a little bit
like it's an extension of your body and
I suspect that that's the same same type
of feeling that would happen if one had
something sort of directly connected to
to neurons in the brain in fact I
suspect it will be a very similar
feeling to that and the question then of
to what extent can you take the things
the brain is otherwise doing and
Outsource them to a piece of electronics
it's a good question I don't think we
know the answer to that because we don't
really know that well what the brain is
actually doing at a level that's
intermediate between what the individual
neurons are doing and the sort of
psychology of thoughts and so on
um but I I would suspect that this is
something we will learn to do and at
that point you know what will it feel
like to have some part of one's thoughts
so to speak uh sort of able to be
executed electronically as opposed to uh
through neurochemistry and so on
well I think it will be interesting
because some of those things that can be
executed electronically will be able to
be done vastly faster than the things
that happen in just our standard
biological brains and so one can imagine
you know it's like well let me think
about what's this long number multiplied
by this other number oh as I think about
that just like I might say the thinking
about that might cause me to type it
into my woven language notebook or
whatever else so the thinking about that
might just send it to my kind of uh uh
sort of on-board piece of electronics
hopefully with a a nice wolf mentioned
thing running in it or whatever which
can then do those computations and then
you get the result back and it's like oh
I know the answer it's this it'll
probably feel a little bit like
retrieving things from your memory where
you don't really know how you retrieve
it from your memory it's not like oh go
fetch that from you know hippocampus
second in some segment number such and
such you just remember it and it's
something that pops into your memory my
guess is that the feeling of something
that comes from a sort of direct brain
connection will be something very much
like that
um and uh so you know I would I would
suspect that that is something that will
will become possible
um I mean it then becomes a very tricky
issue because you know when when it's a
question of programming people the main
the only real way we have to program
people is through education and through
kind of you know explaining things get
people to train get do training of
various kinds all this type of thing
it's it's a very uh it's that kind of
process
um if one gets to the point where one
can say just load in that software and
it's kind of direct to the brain
um that becomes a different story in
terms of how that sort of Education
process works now the thing to recognize
is every brain is different so just like
when somebody tells you if it can be a
whole class of lots of people that are
being explained something the same way
but the way that explanation will play
out in those different brains will be
different
um and so similarly when you're talking
about connecting kind of an electronic
device to a brain the way that whatever
that electronic device does plays out in
that brain will be different for every
brain and no doubt there will have to be
some sort of interface layer that kind
of specializes whatever is being
delivered for each individual brain
um now you know then the question arises
well okay if it's sort of the direct
brain connection and you're kind of uh
you know it's feeding you the thought to
think so to speak how does that uh you
know what is the mechanism by which you
decide well what software do you load in
that will make you think these thoughts
and that becomes a very tricky thing I
mean it's it's you know one can complain
already about the fact that you know
somebody's getting people people to
think the wrong Thoughts by virtue of
the education the the kind of the the
media messaging whatever else it is
um by the time it's kind of that's being
delivered direct to the neurons that
becomes an even more extreme version of
the same kind of thing although although
it really is the same kind of thing
because as I say the way a particular
message sort of plays out will be
different for every particular brain but
it's still something where it's sort of
closer in and it's not something where
it's just it feels much more direct than
just oh well there's this book and it
says these these uh these wonderful
terrible whatever things people should
read it and absorb it it's more there's
this thing that is directly digitally
connected
um and uh but again there's going to be
this layer of uh of kind of
interpretation that's different for
everybody and it's different for every
brain for two reasons one because our
brains are structurally all different
you know our fingerprints are a little
bit different the the full buildings of
our brains are very different person to
person and the the details of how brains
fold and the level of the embryo is
determined by sort of a local
environment and is not something which
is it's there's a few genetic
determinations but it seems to be mostly
it just happens to fold that way
um and so that's one thing the other
thing is we've all had different
experiences and we've all built up
different memories and even given
exposure of uh you know to the exact
same experience the memories that will
be built up will be different even if
there were two sort of identical twins
who were exposed to exactly the same
things which wouldn't you know which is
not really a realistic thing to have
happen
um it's still the case that undoubtedly
the way that those memories will
actually be encoded in the brain will be
different so you know sort of each brain
is different and will interpret that
data even if it comes from a sort of
onboard digital device in a different
way
all right actually the question here was
about damaged parts of the brain with
with the various forms of prosthesis I
think one of the one of the issues there
is if you've damaged a part of the brain
what did you lose
did you lose something that was a unique
memory that was just stored in that part
of the brain for example
um or did you uh or is it something
which can be filled in from other things
in the brain so we know that there's a
certain degree of specialization in
different parts of the brain for
different people you know The Language
Center of the brain is in slightly
different places or the or the you know
there are particular structures in the
brain that seem like they're really
important for recognizing faces for
example one of the things that I think
is true about the brain is whenever
people think oh it's very localized it's
kind of just laid out in engineering way
like a machine where there's this
particular function that occurs in this
particular place it usually turns out
that the story is more complicated than
that and that there's some focal point
but there's other things that are
affected by it Etc but so the question
is if if some part of the brain is
damaged is it possible to you know what
what have you lost and you know for
example you might have damaged a part of
the brain that is in a sense very
procedural and what it does it might be
a part that is responsible for for
signaling to muscles
um you know to do this or that thing it
might be a part that is the direct uh
sort of feeding in of of visual images
or something like this I think those
parts become easier to imagine just
replace that functionality but obviously
in the brain one thing that is sort of
uniquely in the brain is our memories
and it's not clear to what extent the
the memories that we have are localized
they're not completely localized but
they're probably not completely
delocalized either
um there's some sort of complicated way
in which some whole collection of
billions of neurons store what will turn
out to be a coherent memory for us one
of the surprises is that even though we
have all these separate neurons that we
have a coherent sense of what's going on
and we have coherent memories and that's
something there's more to understand and
maybe even some of the ideas from our
physics project the formalism that's
developed there will be relevant for
understanding kind of this process of in
in Neuroscience of kind of going from
the incoherent bundle of stuff that's
stored in all these neurons two coherent
thoughts so to speak but this question
of okay if you damage a piece of the
brain
um how does it affect these coherent
memories that you have that depends on
sort of how distributed the storage of
those memories is and whether you can
kind of fill in oh you know I more or
less remember that oh I've stored that
same thing a hundred times in my brain I
lost 20 of those times that it was
stored because of some piece of damage
to my brain but I've still got 80 of
those things left and oh those 80 that
are there as soon as I re-remember one
of those things it'll generate another
sort of follow-on memory and I'll
gradually fill in those 20 that I lost
and maybe I'll even fill those in not in
my own actual brain but in some digital
piece that's been added to my brain
assuming that identity face can be built
in the right way but yeah so I think I
think this this question is is um uh I'd
be pretty hopeful actually about the
ability to kind of replace eventually
parts of our brains with digital things
and and be able to kind of take the
memories and have them kind of spread
out into those digital Parts but this is
still all some distance away and lots of
technology has to be built to make that
possible plus there are some more basic
science questions about how do brains
really work that still need to be
addressed before and can really do this
in an effective way
let's see
it's a question from Madoff here asking
what ethical implications will become
relevant when we combine machine
learning and brain sensors and effectors
and so on yeah I mean I think that
the thing
that's always relevant to understand
about sort of ethics and machine
learning and Ai and all these kinds of
things is
it's
there's no right answer for ethics it's
not like when we do math or something
like this and we've set up a bunch of
definitions and we just say what's the
right answer it's not even like physics
where we say how does our universe
actually work ethics is a story of what
we humans want to do now to some extent
that's determined by how we are
constructed biologically
um and to some extent that is what we
sort of societally choose to be the way
that we want to to have things work and
when people say well I'm going to get my
machine to decide the ethics of this
that's ultimately kind of a doomed
proposition because in the end one has
to the machine can execute on certain
kinds of ethical decisions can decide oh
I'm going to put this particular uh you
know this particular thing in the in the
news feed for that social media platform
and um uh you know it's the AI will
decide it wants to do that because
that's what the human like or whatever
else it will make those the machine
could be made to make a decision oh
don't put that type of content in that
news feed because it's ethically a bad
thing but it can execute on that but
deciding what's ethically a bad thing
the machine can't do that
at best the machine might be able to
show you some of the consequences of a
particular type of decision but even
that there's a limit to how far you can
go and working out those consequences I
mean that's even a theoretical thing a
thing I figured out in the in the 1980s
this phenomenon of computational
irreducibility that even though you know
the rules by which a system operates to
know the consequences of those rules is
sort of irreducibly hard you have to
actually run the system and see what it
does so you can't expect that um uh see
now this is a great example of of an AI
in action at exactly 413 local time for
some reason the uh the uh the the kind
of um light control system that I have
suddenly switches on a bunch of extra
lights who knows but it seems to happen
every single day and it's a it's a it's
a the machine has a mind of its own
um and uh sort of interesting anyway the
um just always always good to actually
experience the AI in action and no doubt
it perhaps it does that because at some
point ages ago there was some
optimization put in for something that
was supposed to happen every so often
and and now it turns into this but
anyway I was I was talking about AI
ethics
um and uh you know the thing the thing
is
you say I want some kind of um
um
um
you you want the machines to do the
ethically right thing question is what
is the ethically right thing well you
can see what people actually do okay
great then most people would say that
what people actually do you know to
store information and work the eight
billion people on the on the on the
earth actually do in different ethical
situations and so on is probably not
what we want the machines to do because
we want the machines to be our best
selves that might not be our actual
selves so to speak but then the question
is what does it mean to be our best
selves in what direction do you want to
go from what we actually do to be better
and obviously in the in the course of
history people have had all sorts of
cultural Traditions religious traditions
and so on where people have defined what
it is like to be the better us but
that's the challenge is to bottle up
what the better us is and have that be
the the sort of the the Constitution the
rules for the machines but that's a
that's a thing to realize that it is a
choice it's a sort of an arbitrary
choice that is uh I mean it's arbitrary
up to a point if the if the ethical
choices are such that it will cause the
species to go and attack each other and
and just self-destruct and go extinct
that's uh it's kind of a a bad set of
ethical uh choices
um it's kind of a sort of one might say
an existentially bad set of ethical
choices because it will cause the
species to go extinct and then there's
no more ethics to be done so to speak
and presumably we don't want the species
to go extinct
um I mean you know that's a complicated
thing because you could say gosh gosh
you know we really like the uh the way
that nature is and we really like this
or that aspect of the natural world who
are we humans to come and uh disrupt the
natural world wouldn't it be better if
we were extinct
you know as a human uh doesn't seem like
a good deal to me but you know from a
sort of overarching Ethics point of view
you have to kind of decide what you want
I don't think that the I don't think the
universe does not have an ethical
position the universe is not out there
saying gosh it will be better if the
humans didn't exist because the universe
doesn't have ethics ethics are a human
construct and so it's but but it's
something where uh you know beyond the
the statement oh you know we don't want
you know we might have some overarching
ethical principles and certainly in the
course of of human civilization and
history there are some pretty universal
ethical principles that have emerged
um although when you get beyond the very
courses level you start finding that
different cultures have very different
ethical belief systems and choices and
so on and so that that uh you know then
the question is how do you uh for for
the machines and so on it's it's really
uh how do you capture those things in
such a way that a machine can have this
set of ethical principles those are
what's operating according to and now
when it's confronted on a daily on every
micro second basis or something with
particular ethical decisions to be made
that it can follow that code of ethics
that it's been given but in you know the
thing to understand is there is no
ultimate right answer code of ethics so
to speak it's a question of what one
societally chooses
uh
it's some
um
someone's asking is the is the other
mysterious lights of uh Sunset related I
don't think so because I actually think
that I've noticed that at exactly 4 13
um this has happened and it's happened
for enough weeks that um and it's also
uh that that um it isn't the it's not
tied to the moment when the sun is going
uh Over the Horizon
um
let's see Brady is commenting suppose a
rule creates a memory in our brain then
it could be an irreducible problem to
make a true brain interface for any
individual which could interpret a
memory or Concept in terms of a
pre-existing ones
uh yes I mean this is a
um what we have to provide in sort of a
digital interface to the brain has to be
something we can understand there's a
lot we can't understand there is a lot
that is computationally irreducible
there's a lot that we can't reach with
our thinking or our science or whatever
else and so I think one of the
challenges is it's the ultimate user
interface problem you know kind of one
of the goals of a standard piece of user
interface technology ux or language
design for that matter is set up the
things on the computer so we humans can
understand them so we're humans just
looking at them with our eyes we can you
know see oh there's that's peace here
and move that and we press this button
and so on now imagine the ux problem
when you're directly interfacing to the
brain you know we have the notion of
graphic design where we're saying oh
this is you know these are the kinds of
uh structures that people have
recognized are are good for for for
feeling natural in terms of graphic
design and for people to be able to to
pick out the information they want in in
graphic design there will be a whole
other generation of of capability that
we need for essentially neural design
where the question is you know how do we
present that interface in such a way
that our brains can understand it and
it's not that different from user
experience design language design I
suspect I suspect it'll be the same kind
of thing but for example what is I
suppose interesting about it is in
graphic design we're leveraging the kind
of typical experience we have of the
world where if we had graphic design
where there's random pixels lighting up
on the screen it's probably not going to
look very good or be very easy to
understand but we're kind of doing
things which imitate things we've seen
in the real world we have buttons that
imitate things we can press in the real
world we have kind of lines that imitate
things that we see in the real world
and so we're kind of our experience of
the world is being played into this
graphic design similarly with language
design uh computational language design
we're playing into our experience of
human language we've got sort of words
in the computational language that are
kind of a riff on words in in ordinary
human language we're we're playing into
the fact that we already have kind of a
a vernacular way of just talking about
things in terms of language when it
comes to direct brain connection we
don't immediately have that we don't
know we haven't because we haven't been
able to sort of externalize the the
language of the brain we don't know what
the kind of what there is there that we
should be plugging into so to speak I
mean perhaps one step that may happen
from direct brain interfaces is being
able to like display what's happening in
the brain and be able to get it into
something where we can for example use
our visual system to try and interpret
that but that's I think the uh it's kind
of the new generation of user experience
design is neural design and not not
ready yet to have happen but that's a
thing that I think will be sort of the
story of of what has to um uh
um
uh
what has to be um
um uh what has to be done there
let's see
um Paul is commenting
that um if we could completely
understand the human brain might
probably make a copy essentially Fork
the brain into multiple copies
uh yes probably so I mean this is one of
the challenges is can you you know could
you ever expect to scan a brain and and
say now Fork it and get another brain
that's able to do the same thing as that
brain could do uh I I think that's a
that's a question uh you know for
example with a computer
it is
uh it is comparatively simple to Fork a
process running in a computer because
the memory of that process is right
there in digital memory you just get to
you know read it out copy it and this
operation of copying is a
non-destructive operation for human
brains we don't really have a ready
copying readout mechanism for memories
maybe there'll be one one day maybe one
day there'll be a mechanism that is
completely non-invasive that reads out
human memories where you don't have to
go in and you know in principle you go
and look at those neurons The Memories
We don't really know how the memories
are stored but probably they're stored
in things like calcium channels that
exist in the synapses that are the
connections between neurons it's
literally more little little dots of of
calcium channels on those synapses that
form as a result of a sort of a memory
being created the sort of at the at the
smallest level the memory is is sort of
the connectivity of those neurons and
that's determined by by those things
like those calcium channels
um and uh and potentially if we just had
the neuron right in front of us we might
be able to even with some uh powerful
microscope or something take it apart
and say how what was the connection to
that neighboring neuron now the the
question is is that something that we
can do without taking apart all the
neurons there's sort of some hope that
with things like optogenetics where you
get to have um uh where you get to add
things to uh the the sort of genetic
setup of something that like jellyfish
can produce light
um then you can start to do things where
when this is happening and not only is
it metabolizing doing chemical kinds of
things which we can't immediately detect
but it's also doing chemical things that
produce light which we can which we can
see and use and have sensors that detect
that and so that's one kind of approach
but I think it's not it's by no means
out of the question that one day there
will be the possibility of completely
non-invasively you know scanning a brain
and saying here are the memories in this
brain here particularly if we understand
how the memories are encoded you know
one of the things that's been sort of a
feature of the development of technology
and science has been a lot of effects
where we said we'll never be able to
measure that it's just too small in
effect eventually one's able to measure
it I mean I always find it remarkable in
for example archeology that it's
possible to start saying you know this
meal that was eaten you know 5 000 years
ago what was in that meal well we got a
few DNA molecules here we know the type
of sheep it was that it was in the stew
we know you know the detail of of what
temperature this was cooked at Etc et
cetera et cetera that in other words
that one of the features of of the
progression of technology is the ability
to read out sort of more and more uh
finer and finer detail of things and so
I don't consider it by any means
impossible that there'll be a time when
it's possible to kind of read out uh uh
sort of read out all the memories of a
brain now you know once you have that
um then then you can potentially have
sort of a digital clone of the brain you
know I have to say one of the things
I've certainly thought is is that that
well there are memories that are
internally stored in the brain but there
are experiences and the things we do and
I've for the last 30 something years
have been storing lots of my kind of uh
experiences you know every keystroke I
type and all those kinds of things and
all the messages I send and all sorts of
other all sorts of other things that um
I've sort of stored about myself and
plus you know I do things like live
streaming and so on where I'm sort of
externalizing things that are in my
brain in some sense and so it is not
obvious to me the extent to which all of
that sort of digital exhaust that I've
been producing
um of uh of keystroke logs and all this
kind of thing to what extent one will be
able to say it doesn't matter whether
you scan that brain there's still enough
externalized stuff that one can
reconstruct everything that that brain
would do so to speak and so that there's
there's enough stored that given a thing
with the same capabilities as a brain
that one can just sort of Feed in all
those things and have that brain that
sort of copy brain
um be able to to be in the sort of same
state as the original brain
um
so let's see
uh
it's a question here from spare asking
do you think neurons do that signal
processing based mostly on discrete
States or on the temporal difference
between states
you know people are always making claims
about this and I I've never really dug
into this deeply myself this question of
of um to what extent what matters about
a neuron is does it fire or not does it
have that little electrical pulse that
it generates or not and does it do that
in a particular millisecond does it do
that in particular uh 100th of a second
or whatever
um or not but then people say well
actually what's important is that inside
the all little dendritics uh dendrites
dendritic spines and so on that exist or
all the little places where there are
connections to the main body of the
neuron that there's a lot of complicated
uh sort of signal processing and
information processing happening in that
whole tree of connections some people
say that that's important I don't know I
don't think we really know some people
even say that the molecular details of
well for example the microtubules on the
surface of the cells and so on are
important in do doing information
processing we certainly know that when
neurons do their thing they initiate
protein synthesis so they're actually
producing molecules does it matter
what's happening at the level of
molecules or is that merely part of the
process of of cementing in some rather
direct sense of memory in a neuron for
instance we just don't know at what
level these things are operating we
don't know whether kind of the the time
sequence of those Spike Trends important
there are places where it probably is so
for example in our ears where what's
happening is we have these hair cells in
our ears that are being wiggled by sound
waves that are that are coming into our
ears and um uh the there is some well
actually even there maybe it I don't
know the the you might think that the
way a brain would do it is there's a
sound wave you know when we talk we
maybe have a few thousand uh vibrations
per second that are the relevant uh free
frequencies for a human speech for
instance and you might think well why
doesn't the brain just make use of the
fact that neurons can be firing you know
a thousand times a second or whatever
it's just like just take that directly
in and um uh and just just ingest that
Direct Time series of when did the hair
cell wiggle in the in the cochlear
inside the inner ear that would be
strategy number one strategy number two
which is the one actually used it seems
by by us is arrange the hair cells and
the arrange the inner ear so that
different frequencies kind of excite
hair cells in different places on the
cochlea so you're kind of making
something that's kind of like an inverse
piano so to speak a piano the keys are
laid out so the higher frequency ones
are on the right hand side and so on
what you're doing is the inverse of that
you're having something where the the
place where
um you know sound comes in and the the
hair cells on the on one end are the
high frequency ones the hair cells on
the other end of the low frequency ones
and our at the level of the sort of
Hardware of our ears we're doing that
kind of frequency analysis to turn what
was otherwise sort of these compression
waves or whatever else happening
thousands of times per second into
something which is a a spatial layout of
different kinds of frequencies so that's
kind of a piece of evidence that the
brain at least in that case isn't
choosing to use just the the straight
you know compression goes straight in
you know sequence of compressions and so
on go straight into the brain the brain
is doing an analysis a frequency
analysis before doing that now sort of
analogous to what happens with let's say
radio in in the case of uh uh back in
the day when people had sort of ordinary
radio receivers you would tune your
radio to be able to uh to detect a radio
signal coming from a radio transmitter
that was operating at a particular
frequency in modern times there's the
idea of software radio where you're
really just ingesting the whole signal
and you're letting the the the processor
of the computer take it apart and say oh
there's a part that corresponds to this
frequency and that frequency and so on
that would be more something where
you're really directly using the sort of
the sequence of of amounts of energy
coming in onto your antenna or whatever
else that will be like the brain from
our ears directly using the wiggling of
you know the of the of the eardrum or
whatever we don't actually do that we
spatialize it and feed that into
different nerves in the auditory cortex
in the brain so that's kind of a piece
of like circumstantial evidence that our
brain is not set up so much to use the
the particular time sequence at least on
the on the on the level of of uh
um of um
what's happening in speech now in terms
of whether it matters what that time
series is of you you you go click click
click now and then a few milliseconds
later you're clicking differently I
don't think anybody knows whether that's
important or not and you know it like
most things in biology
you know one of the frustrating things
about biology sometimes uh less so
molecular biology but biology in general
is that it's always more complicated
than you can possibly imagine there's
always more different effects going on
and well it's mostly this but there's a
little bit of that and so on it's it's
funny because you know I have I have
friends who are into biology medicine
things like that and and they sometimes
they're confronted with questions that
are really questions of physics and they
just don't have the same they have an
intuition that always says it's going to
be complicated there isn't just a slam
dunk answer and in physics there often
is a slam dunk answer there is no signal
propagating through this particular uh
you know copper box or something zero
just doesn't there isn't any it's not
like in biology where you say well there
isn't really any way in which uh you
know the some some genetic information
can go back from the organism to the DNA
well when we say there isn't any there
is some it's just not very important
um and you know in biology there are
there are often these kind of exception
cases and so I think when one says oh it
never matters you know what the temporal
sequence of the spike trains is I bet
that's not true I bet there's a case
where it matters
um and or some little way in which it
matters you know if you if you change it
too much something will go wrong and so
on
the um
uh
let's see
question here about um
huh
William comments even though brains are
different don't they all implement the
same underlying ideas doesn't this point
to some platonic realm of reality oh boy
lovely philosophy question I mean in
in
to what extent
is there a sort of a there there for
Concepts to what extent is there a
robust notion of a concept independent
of its implementation in the brain
one of the things we learned from
computation is that there is a
robustness to abstract things that
transcends the details of how they're
implemented in Hardware it doesn't
matter that one person has a Mac and one
person has a PC they can still run the
same well from language code they can
still be doing the same kind of
computational have the same represent
the same kinds of thing computational
things even though the underlying
Hardware is different and I'm sure the
same thing is true with brains that this
Universal Computing idea that even in
different Hardware you can implement the
same ideas that's what's happening in
brains as well that's why we can have a
common set of abstract ideas is because
our different brains are all sort of
universal machines that can all
Implement those same abstract ideas and
the choice of which abstract ideas to
implement well that's where it gets
interesting because that's where kind of
civilization and knowledge and sort of
paradigms and things come in because
that's what determines of all the
infinite things we could Implement with
our brains the actual Concepts that we
choose to represent in our brains are
the ones that are the ones that we've
sort of culturally learned we care about
um and so you know that's the place
where we're kind of commonizing that's
the place where things are becoming in
common is that thread of kind of shared
cultural uh knowledge and and
interesting things
um even though the underlying Hardware
implementation will be different for
every brain you know in a very abstract
way in what we've studied with this
thing we call the ruliad which is kind
of the ultimate limit of all of physics
and Mathematics the the the ultimate
limit of all possible computations and
so on
um maybe uh yeah the the um one of the
things that happens there is one is
asking different points in this rouliad
correspond to essentially different
points of view about how we think the
universe works different ways in which
we represent the goings-on of the
universe and so one question is if you
want to travel from one place in the
rouliad to another you want to sort of
change your point of view about how
things work in the world how do you do
that and is there is there what what
kinds of things can transport from one
place to another and what seems to be
the case is that particles
we're used to particles traveling in
space like electrons and photons and
things like that are these kind of lumps
of of of of of of of
existence that travel unchanged from one
place to another the electron starts
here and it moves somewhere else the
structure the underlying structure of
the universe the underlying structure of
space might be very different in those
two places but yet there can be an
electron this lump of existence that can
go from one place to another in some
sense unchanged so when we think about
the rouliad and we think about all these
different Minds kind of embedded at
different places in the rouliad and we
imagine what can be transported from one
place one point of view to another what
can be transported unchanged what's the
analog of a particle in Rule's space I
think the answer is a concept that is a
concept the concept of a cat the concept
of
um you know happiness or something these
are things which are represented
differently in each individual brain to
each individual mind but nevertheless
they are transportable they are like
particles that they can move to a
different brain and be interpreted in
that of the brain and so I think that's
kind of the analog that's the thing that
that it is and the fact that there is
this world of sort of a particle physics
of ideas
um that's the thing which I suppose
transcends the the uh uh you know that's
the thing that is kind of like tonic
realm of pure ideas now what's
interesting to understand is just like
we imagine there's a particular way
physics works with photons and electrons
and all that kind of thing what are the
global rules of this kind of conceptual
world of of how can Concepts interact
how can we make a description so to
speak for that and I think what we're
what we'll discover there is that a
large part of that story has to do with
how our minds and brains actually work
that is that it isn't the case that sort
of anything goes into the the types of
particles the types of of rule particles
the types of concept particles that we
deal with are ones that for whatever
reason our brains are set up to be able
to detect you know it is the case that
we're very familiar with photons we
didn't know that they were made of you
know that light was made of individual
uh element pieces of energy like that
and so on until 100 years ago but um uh
the fact that you know there's light and
we detect light and so on that's very
familiar to us if there was some strange
kind of particle that's you know some
dark matter particle or something that
um although I'm I'm decreasingly uh
convinced that dark matter is a thing
but that's a different story
um but in any case the the you know if
there's some something like that where
it's just some completely different sort
of sector of physics we don't happen to
have detectors for that that emerge from
our biology and so we're completely we
completely don't know about that kind of
World
um that that's uh you know that's sort
of a separate possibility from the
things that are part of the net of
Concepts that we already know about
let's see uh
uh yes so Tony is commenting one of the
issues of being able to read and decode
a memory is that someone will have to
will
have the ability to write artificial
memories in a brain
um
yeah well
you know it's a funny thing because
you know people watch movies people read
books of fiction people have dreams for
example these are all things that didn't
really happen in some sense and they are
going into our memories and somehow we
managed to deal with that and not get
sort of irreducibly confused about
what's real and what's not uh I don't
know what will happen when kind of
there's sort of artificial digital
memories and it's kind of like well that
seems like a memory you know is that
real is that a thing that was something
that happened in a dream for example
um I don't know whether we'll have an
easy time distinguishing those or
whether whether it will be possible for
the digital memory to kind of masquerade
as a real memory and then what
consequences that has and and that's a
very you know this is a very complicated
ethical thing because it's kind of like
well I want to remember you know uh
the nature of us is based on our
memories if you start messing around
with what those memories are you no
longer have an us so to speak you no
longer have the same person in some
sense and and so what does it mean and
at what point you know how do you uh
kind of um well you know people make all
kinds of decisions about themselves
um uh sometimes they're ones that from
the outside look sensible and sometimes
the ones that from the outside look
completely crazy
um but you know the decision to kind of
um change
um uh
you know the um
um uh uh kind of uh sort of make a
change oh I don't want to remember that
let's just erase that forever see again
I don't know how that will really work
because there's there's externalized
versions of memories and you know you'll
kind of remember that you remembered it
and it's it's all complicated I mean
some of this has been addressed in in
science fiction I noticed prabh is
commenting about a touring test for
memories like an Inception yeah there's
this movie Inception about you know
dreams and dreams within dreams and and
things like this I found that movie
super hard to understand I I maybe I may
have the deficiency that I'm one of
these people who very rarely remembers
dreams that I have
um which I consider in some ways
fortunate because then I don't have to
have this confusion of did it happen for
real or did it happen in a dream I I
don't have that question
um it's uh
um it uh anyway I think that the um but
this question of is it a real memory or
is it not a real memory very interesting
thing to wonder whether whether one will
be able to tell is that memory of memory
was that a memory it's just like you
know you you see a um a piece of text
that's been written and somebody says oh
it's written by one of these uh neural
Nets that is a you know a text generator
and you say really or was it written by
a person and you kind of look at it and
sometimes you can really plainly tell
and sometimes it's a little bit harder
at least to tell
um or you know this piece of artwork was
it made by what's every stuff of it made
by a human artist or was it all
aggregated by some neural Nets or
something like this and I suppose you
could ask the same thing about them and
you could say can we tell can we can we
tell the difference and you know the the
bad part for us humans is look there are
places where we're not going to be able
to tell the difference there are places
where uh it's just kind of it's kind of
leveraging it's following the way that
we humans do things it's saying look
I've seen a million things that are what
you humans produce I'm going to make one
that's just like what you produce and
you'll look at and you'll say oh that
looks like something a human produced
because the neural net the machine
Learning System learned from a million
things that that humans had produced so
yeah I think it's something where the
unless where it's like when you're
showing things that are just like humans
produced up to a point it's going to
look kind of like uh it's going to look
just like what you know what the humans
have produced before now when it comes
to things like Memories it's an
interesting question whether there'll be
sort of small scale pieces of memories
that have the right texture that they
say oh that seems like a real memory I
think our dreams for example are
probably you know they're a small
fragments of memory that kind of look
right they have the right texture but
globally the whole thing may make no
sense that things that come from sort of
random excitation of the brain and we've
excited some particular memory and a
right around that memory oh yes it's
coherent enough enough that we can tell
that's a you know that's related to a
memory of some uh you know some giant
tortoise we saw when we were five years
old or some such other thing
um and uh the the um uh you know and
it's it's coherent up to a point but
somehow the tortoise then segues and we
tend to make these these connections you
know then segues into well it's actually
an airplane type thing or something like
this
um and uh you know our brains do pretty
well at kind of you know putting that
merge in there and so will the AIS do
well at doing that and so locally the
thing may make sense now when you say is
there a big picture is there sort of a a
big there there there may not be that's
that's the thing that is much harder and
that relates much more to the thing that
is really not what AIS intrinsically do
I mean AIS intrinsically are a piece of
automation that takes kind of human
goals and tries to sort of fill in how
to actually execute them but if you say
to the AI hey what do you intrinsically
want to do you know you're just a
computer what do you want to do
on the computer is is either somebody
programmed it to say you know I want to
go to the moon or something
um or it's just gonna sit there and it's
a computer and we humans by virtue of
both our biological construction and our
experiences end up with these and I
really do want to do this so that
whether it's go to the moon or something
else
um and uh it's you know I think that
that is something where that's not
intrinsically a machine AI kind of thing
to know sort of what's the uh what the
purpose is and I think when you get to
these sort of larger scale structures it
more relates to what purpose is going on
and I think that's the place where you
start to see kind of almost the Turing
test for for memories and so on I mean I
suppose that in some sense and I I don't
know to what extent you know a lot of
the sort of Turing test ideas and people
who use in a wolf and Alpha to collect
connect to Turin test Bots and things
like that us a lot of what's going on
there is is pretty small scale is the
texture rate of answering individual
questions but you know when it comes to
the big picture did this make sense I
just had a half hour conversation with
this thing did it really make sense or
is it just a bunch of random textually
correct pieces that were stuck together
that's probably where the where the test
of of uh kind of something real comes in
but yeah it's an interesting question
what would one be able to tell with a
digital memory what you know is this
does this look real it's just like you
know when you have sound effects in
movies you know things can sound really
real even though you know it's actually
just somebody knocking two pieces of
wood together and so on but it just
sounds real as you know I don't know a
horse you know Galloping around or
whatever else it is and you know there's
the question and when we have sort of
visual things there are things that can
look really real we happen to be very
sensitive for example human faces where
it's been really difficult to make a
realistic looking human face that is
produced sort of in an AI way although
it's getting getting easier to do that
and I think that's a question of what
will it feel like for digital memories
what will we say that's really crummy
that's a that's an artificially made
Thing versus that has the texture to be
a convincing memory that I don't know
the
um
let's see
uh
William is commenting perhaps the only
difference between dreams and reality is
a matter of degree perhaps it just
depends on logical coherence once the
coherence is larger than what the brain
can be aware of it is considered real
it's an interesting claim I mean the
claim would be that that um uh the world
is a coherent place
and we recognize that kind of larger
scale coherence whereas when we're
having internal thoughts and a dream
we're not being driven that's not being
driven by the external coherence of the
world that's an interesting thought and
I think one of the things that is
obviously the case is that our
experience of the world and the world as
world as we experience it is a fairly
coherent place you know I've been been
sitting in one place for the last hour
or something and nothing dramatic has
changed you know it's not the case that
that uh the the walls of the room have
disintegrated and replaced by some
flowing complicated you know
configuration of this that or the other
and you know the the world is is kind of
maintains coherence now if we were an
environment let's say we're in some kind
of virtual reality where there isn't
that kind of coherence I wonder what
that feels like I I don't know I think
that a lot of what's done right now in
in VR is in sort of the metaverse type
type direction is let's emulate let's
have sort of a slight tweak on
experience as we currently have it but
not let's just go crazy and have
something where that there's just this
what seemed to us like random pixels
pixels being generated by some algorithm
that is full of computational
irreducibility and we're just being in
you know uh we're being submerged in
this kind of artificial world that does
not have the coherence that we associate
with the physics physics as we perceive
it an interesting question what that
will feel like my guess is it will feel
incredibly disorienting and my guess is
that it's kind of a that it's not good
for your brain to expose it to that
actually I'm surprised people haven't
done those experiments maybe maybe they
haven't I'm not aware of it
um that uh to try and sort of live in an
environment that just doesn't have
coherence where just random things that
have seen things that seem random to us
are happening all the time but we can't
make sense of what's going on my guess
is that one kind of um uh loses it very
quickly that it's really hard to that
one will get very disoriented very
confused uh almost kind of uh uh not not
capable of maintaining sort of the
country Consciousness that we normally
have
um it's uh
I think um that's an interesting
question it should be an interesting
experiment to do I'm not sure I'm I'm
not sure I'm the one who's signing up to
go and uh hang out in the incoherent
virtual reality
um that seems uh uh seems Seems
difficult
um
all right uh
well I think I need to get going here
but um a lot of interesting discussion
here I might have to say somebody's
mentioning um dark dark matter
um Dark Energy uh I've been studying I
think I've said this too many times I've
been studying the second law of
Thermodynamics law of entropy increase
for the last several months actually
because I've realized that some things
we've done in our physics project kind
of open up a bunch of things that people
have been confused about including
myself I've been confused about these
things for 50 years the world in general
has been confused about them for 150
years so but in any case one of the
things that I'm really struck by in the
early days of the development of ideas
about thermodynamics there was this idea
of the caloric theory of heat where the
idea was that heat is a fluid that kind
of suffuses all substances and that's
what heat is as we know now heaters you
know the emotional molecules and so on
but I I just have this this tremendous
image of dark matter is the caloric
fluid of modern times that it's not what
you think it is it's not something which
is described you know at the time when
people were talking about caloric fluid
people knew there was air as sort of a
fluid and there was water as a fluid and
fluids were a thing that was a sort of
description for how things work in the
world they didn't think of the idea or
some people did but mostly they didn't
think of the idea it's motion of
molecules and and I think the same is
happening probably with dark matter and
so on the people say well it's you know
what we know about is particles it must
just be other particles but it's
actually probably something which takes
a bit more creativity and Imagination to
realize and our physics project should
be able to tell one what kinds of things
might be out there that are not what you
thought were there and so uh that's uh
that's one of the things I I hope to
work on soon
um it's uh
um
Parker is commenting here with
co-evolved our environment so it should
be coherent to us but if we inject
things into our environment that we
haven't co-evolved with we'll get
confused yeah it's a good point and just
to finish on this I mean the the the
we build our environment and then we
kind of you know we decide windows are
are rectangular usually whatever we
don't
um when we and this is one feature of
for example modern architecture is this
idea you know for a long time in
architecture for example we built things
that were kind of the way that it was
easy to make the construction work and
the way that the so the physics of the
thing would not cause the structure to
fall down or whatever and sometimes we
built things that would be kind of
reminiscent of features of human form or
the natural world or whatever else and
then we have kind of modern architecture
and modern materials where you can make
any shape you want you can make it work
any way you want and it is an
interesting experience because that type
of thing I think the general experience
people have is it's a bit disorienting
sometimes you're you know there's a
certain set of things you're familiar
with and they're not disoriented partly
because of familiarity but partly
because they are they are the things
that are part of the natural world and
things like this when you go kind of off
the reservation and you're you're kind
of in this in this world where anything
goes it tends to be the experience that
we tend to have is one of disorientation
now some people say that's good
disorientation because it kind of gets
you to to think differently other people
say that's uncomfortable uh
disorientation and so on but I think
it's it's and it is true that we we tend
to create things I mean if that some
particular kind of modern architecture
with some particular kind of swirly
thing in it became the standard we would
then get familiar with that and that
would become the thing on which we base
our thinking our language
Etc et cetera Etc and I think the um uh
and yes that that that's sort of a it's
an interesting circle of the things we
come up with to think about other things
that then become things that we work
with and that we build into our
environment so those become familiar and
that that becomes the thing that is our
sort of uh comfortable experience and so
on
all right lots of interesting topics
um thanks very much for for all those
questions and comments and um uh I look
forward to
um doing this again and uh thanks for
joining me and uh bye for now